das ist schon ein bisschen verrückt eine
forschungsgruppe sucht eigentlich nach
planet 9
dabei liegt aber der jupiter genau vor
der vermuteten fundstelle vom planet 9
und stattdessen quasi im vorbeigehen
findet das forschungsteam zwölf neue
gestürmt in unserem sonnensystem alle
infos dazu jetzt den blick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
auch so funktioniert wissenschaft man
sucht nach etwas und findet etwas ganz
anderes so seiner forschungsgruppe um
scott sheppard von der carnegie
institution for science gegangen
eigentlich wollten sie endlich eine spur
vom planeten entdeckt man vermutet ja
dass es sich dabei um einen
gesteinsplaneten handelt und dass er
wohl den vierfachen durchmesser der erde
hat und maximal zehn mal so groß ist wie
unser heimatplanet er muss sich nach
ansicht vieler forschungsteam wohl am
äußersten rande des sonnensystems
versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen
verschiedene objekte in dieser region
lassen darauf schliessen konkret geht es
um rund 20 größere objekte im
kupfergürtel ein gebiet außerhalb der
neptun waren nach schätzungen von
astronomen und astronomen sind dort
zahlreiche kleine und wohl mehr als
70.000 objekte zu finden die einen
durchmesser von mehr als 100 kilometern
haben weswegen man planet 9 bis heute
trotz intensiver suche noch nicht direkt
beobachten konnte
das liegt wohl an seiner enormen distanz
zur sonne amerikanische wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen vom institute
of technology california haben berechnet
dass die bahn vom planet neuen den
planeten zu dem zeitpunkt seiner
dichtesten er wohl immer noch 700 mal
weiter an der sonne vorbei führt als die
erde inzwischen wurden viele
informationen über den mysteriösen
riesenplaneten analysiert und mit hilfe
von computermodellen komplizierte
simulationen erstellt ein team hatte das
komplette letzte jahr analysiert wie
planet 9 mit anderen planeten und dem
rest des sonnensystems inter geht dabei
sei man schon ein gutes stück
weitergekommen seine mögliche position
am himmel ein zu kämpfen
dieses jahr findet die systematische
suche am himmel statt aber bisher ist
man noch nicht fündig geworden wobei so
ganz stimmt es ja nicht jetzt hat eben
ein forschungsteam quasi als zufallsfund
zwölf neue jupiter monde entdeckte 11
der monde haben einen durchmesser von
einem bis drei kilometer neun davon sind
teil eines jahr waren mond schwarz in
einiger entfernung zu dem gasplaneten
der alle zwei jahre einmal um den
jupiter kreis wahrscheinlich liegt der
ursprung dieses schwarz in drei größeren
objekten die einmal auseinander
gebrochen sind zwei der entdeckten monde
gehören zu einer gruppe die dichter um
die planeten kreist und nur ein jahr für
eine umrundung benötigen
einer der entdeckten monde ist
allerdings ein sonderling er umkreist
den jupiter alle anderthalb jahre und
ist mit weniger als einem kilometer der
kleinsten bisher entdeckte jupitermond
seine umlaufbahn ist wohl ziemlich
instabil und dass das forschungsteam
vermutet eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit
der kollision mit anderen objekten mit
den neu entdeckten monden sind jetzt
insgesamt 79 monde bekannt die um den
gasriesen kreisen ist er ist damit der
planet im sonnensystem mit den meisten
monden und es ist nicht unwahrscheinlich
dass noch mehr in der nächsten zeit
gefunden werden der jupiter ist übrigens
so riesig und so hell dass er ganz
leicht mit bloßem auge am nachthimmel
entdeckt werden kann
und er ist auch so groß dass er sogar
als kleine scheibe zu sehen ist versucht
es mal und schreibt mir in den
kommentare ob ihr den gasplaneten am
himmel entdeckt habt das ist ja
inzwischen mit dem der ein oder anderen
app ziemlich leicht hinzubekommen
ja und wenn ihr kein video mehr
verpassen wollte also wenn erfahren
wollt wenn neue monde zum beispiel
gefunden werden um den jupiter
dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht
ihr die kaputt arburg sie auf youtube
und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen und das täglich
und das garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten noch mal
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau die klopper
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken planet 9
die schlinge zieht sich zu bis dann
bleibt dran